بينما تتوافد الحافلات الى القاهره ليلا
ونهارا يستقبل الركاب المنهكين من وعثاء
السفر شباب سوداني مقيم في مصر بزجاجات
المياه والوجبات الخفيفه فهم يعلمون ان
هؤلاء النازحين قطعوا رحله متوسطها ثلاثه
ايام على اقل تقدير حتى دخلوا مصر امنين
ولكن المتطوعين رفضوا الحديث للكاميرا
زهدا منهم في ظهور الاعلامي انا بشكر
الشباب السودانيه طبعا موقف
ثانيا يعني موق شباب السوداني لا يعني
ايوه ايوه يعني انهم هم التطوع ان هم
يقولوا انه
اي حد هيوصله مجان وقابل مويه اول ما
نزلنا لو عندكم مشكله بتاعه السكن ولا ولا
كده
بتدعم الناس
وبتساعد الناس وكده يعني ما شايف حاجه
شايفه حاجه كويسه والله مبادره انسانيه
تمتلئ بها صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي يقوم
بها افراد متطوعون بغض النظر عن
الانتماءات والانحيازات بعض الجمعيات
الاهليه تستهدف ما هو اوسع من نطاق توزيع
المواد الغذائيه او الادويه فهم يرون ان
امامهم عملا شاقا لازاله اثار الاحداث
الجاريه في السودان عن الاذهان وانا
امبارح الكلام اللي شفته في الباصات يعني
ناس كانت مقتدره بتتكلم بصغاع في انه نحن
يعني قدرنا نطلع والحمد لله يعني عندنا
شقق لكن احنا محتاجين دعم نفسي لانه الخوف
اللي دخل في اطفالهم مش حيطلع بالسهوله
احنا الان دربنا تيم هذا التيم يعمل على
الدعم النفسي للاسر القادمه احساس بالامان
في مصر هو دعم نفسي من احنا عندنا تجربه
قبل كده في هذا الاجتماع يناقش اعضاء
الجمعيه ترتيبات سفر فريق عمل لمدينه
اسوان والتي تستقبل اعدادا كبيره من
النازحين يوميا
القافله هيتحرك هذه المقاله الجمعيه
بالقاهره الى اسوان حتكون في ان شاء الله
باذن الله من خلال هذه القافله
عدد كبير برضو من الناس اللي بتحاول بقدر
الامكان انها تعمل دراسه حاله
للمتضررين لكي تعرف الاحتياجات ولا يخلو
عمل هذه الجمعيه وغيرها من تقديم
المساعدات العينيه والاعداد لها وهم هنا
يقومون باختيار عدد من الاصناف الاساسيه
التي يرون ان الاسره ستحتاج اليها كمواد غ
ذائيه خاصه في الايام الاولى لهم تامر
نصرت العربيه القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات